ce soir une fois sketches inédits pour
les pertes et c'est parti les ses
valises hier parti après le dépôt des
poney pour les siens oui cristiano de
poids des pôles christien mais ce que tu
me reçoit areva t d affaire m'a dit ok
en resta là finisterre du wifi
pourquoi tu me derrière tu veux te dire
apparemment vous dormiez excusez moi
c'est plus fort que moi je veux pas
rester sans rien faire
vous êtes christian oui de la brigade
des feuilles à châtel je me présente et
gilbert lavergne l'élève rotofil heures
c'est toi les numéros offerts aux
malades il y aura peut-être un à leur
tour filaire moi je voyais personne a
rejeté sur le qui vive
tenez je vous remets ma convocation je
vous dérange pas au moins tu peux me
tutoyez on est de gauche
alors elle est bien de la convocation
il ya les deux signatures y aller tu as
beau verbe aussi met au boulot je
déconne
tu es prend le temps en prenant le temps
de nous connaître par le mois de toi
comment es tu arrivé ici en bus mais non
quand on est arrivé ici ton parcours ton
cursus quoi tu as fait un j'ai toujours
eu envie de faire ça c'est un genre de
vacation en quelque sorte il mon père
était de la d2 me fais pas pareil non
c'est pas le même prestige
qu'est ce qui faisait son père à la dde
il était guetteur beau pour voir si des
voitures arrivent et vous déjà pour
prévenir les autres pour qu'ils se
remettent au boulot quoi tu connais le
village de labastide saint pierre
non c'est la wam a travaillé non c'est
ça qu'on va goûter maintenant moi je
vois jamais alors à gênes ont fait un
métier où on va retravailler des
calories alors avant de l'écraser il
faut les com magazine est apparemment
vous est pris de l'avancé
un peu alors tu vas voir le labastide
saint pierre était petit verre bien
sympathique
tu voir et la texture du petrus a quand
même
il a la couleur du margaux raconte
comment il a bien le goût de la bastille
de cette bière alors patron pas trop pas
trop pas trop versé ma bouteille et dis
moi franchement à quoi tu ne trouves
asie vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y tu le perds
pas de vue dans l'organisme c'est vrai
mais c'est ce qu'on appelle un bel gps
on sait toujours où il est
et il en reste des habitants à labastide
saint pierre oui une fois par iphone et
dégustations et s'appelle de saint
génocide
ils viennent pas le reste de l'équipe et
non mais ne viendront plus qu'elle
faisait reprendre le tachymètre les
blues il fait nuit non non non non non
non non pas plus que les retraites c'est
l'heure de la galette des rois ils vont
pas venir inquiéter des rois et on est
au mois d'avril
et alors tu le connais pas le principe
et la galette des rois mois de janvier
était un collègue qui arrive au dépôt
idées aux autres et les mecs ça vous
dirait de tirer les rois tout le monde
voit génial le mec il a rêvé qu'une
grande galette qui passe sous le bureau
des coupes au départ au hasard et un
cherche à la fève y en ait qui la trouve
c'est le roi qu'est ce que feu lumineux
couronne qu'est ce qu'il doit faire il
doit racheter nos galettes
le lendemain il reviendra sous le bureau
des coups donnés par waza recherche la
fève y en a qui la trouve c'est le roi
lumineux galette qui rachète une galette
et que tu évites au mois de juillet de
seuil et peuvent vous trouvez des
galettes en toute saison
ah non à partir du mois de mai en
s'adaptant fait que des tarte aux
cerises juillet des tartes à la pêche en
outre des tentes aux réserves et se
retenir jusqu'à toussaint au fait que
des cèpes et c'est peu dire war c'est un
peu le roi tient beau métier
c'est sûr que c'est un beau métier
croyez que vont aussi un jour je serai
un employé modèle peut-être parce qu'ils
vont devoir marcher lentement comme ça
se dit pour le faire pertes sur prêts
municipal cette amitié
synopsis une philosophie un abri mis six
pales c'est un fait mais on ne le voit
pas arriver on ne l'entend pas repartir
un peu comme s'il n'était pas venu comme
et yeux voilà tu vois moi je fais
toujours le même rêve je rêve que la la
phrase à tiers seraient employées
municipales tout le pays ne serait qu'un
ballet de blues aux couleurs
multicolores
22h45 l'heure de la mort je suis dans
mon casier l'heure du choix posés nous
et verte ou blouson bleu le temps de se
décider midi viennent de sonner
alors ces caisses de retraite les
réunions syndicales et il leur de s'y
remettre
alors le soir harassé mais le coeur
léger
nous rentrons dans nos foyers tu pleures
petit oui chef
ce monde ne soit qu il un jour et à
lille sera petit alors pour récompenser
notre ténacité nous pourront chanter ce
chant si beau le champ des employés
municipaux feuilles
ado c'est le chant des municipaux fait
râteau c'est bientôt l'heure de l'apéro
richesse